pete carroll the seahawks head coach
yesterday after a mock game that was
held
before which the anthem was played and
multiple members of the team sat during
the anthem pete carroll was asked about
the uh the current atmosphere the
current climate and where it could lead
for the nfl here's some of what pete had
to say
you know i heard heard doc rivers
talking today and and uh
doctor did a great job of stating this
is just ridiculous that we're putting up
this is i can't even imagine that this
continues to happen
how i don't know how somebody could ever
do that under the circumstances and the
awareness that everybody should have
right now but it continues to happen so
it continues to be a real problem
and there's a lot of problems and but
that's just one of the ones that just
jumps out at us and so i'm really
applaud those guys for for taking the
night and uh but that we all know that's
not enough it's just a statement and the
the
what is important and everybody that's
involved knows it's what we do about it
and what we keep doing to straighten
things out and get things right
this whole thing is it's ridiculous and
anybody that doesn't recognize that just
isn't paying attention and so uh
yeah we're on it too does it seem
possible an nfl team would not take the
field or your team wouldn't take the
field because of this
uh you know
anything's possible i i mentioned to the
players this is the year
it's the protest season you know
it's a season of protest and uh so we'll
you know we'll handle ourselves as we do
and um
but it's this is this is a protest that
doesn't have an end to it until until
all the problems go away
well that that's a hell of a goal and i
don't know how realistic it is but but i
think that's what the players want to
see they want to see that they're being
heard yeah and that they're not being
dismissed that it's not just lip service
yeah we hear you we're taking care of
that well what what are you doing right
about it yeah what's your plan of action
so what are we doing everything yeah no
no no
go higher why don't yes right i know
you're right right yeah every owner in
the nfl other than shot khan
and kim pagula co-owner of the bills
shad khan owner of the jaguars every
other owner white
what is the nfl collectively going to do
about this now look the nfl has made a
push for increased voter registration
and then that's good that's one tangible
thing but i feel like this moment calls
out for something more and it needs to
be a loud voice it needs to be a unified
voice and it needs to be
something that shows it's not just
saying what needs to be said to check
the box and get the players to not walk
out and you know pete carroll won't
close the door on the possibility of a
walkout and chris on top of everything
else we are going to be monitoring as
this season unfolds that ever present
risk of a covert 19 outbreak that
there's an ever-present risk now that
something will happen
that will cause players the night before
a game the day of a game
or right up until kickoff to say
we're not doing it yeah we will not play
we refuse to take the field under these
circumstances sports are a reward for a
functional society and we are currently
not functional no we are not we are
totally dysfunctional the most
dysfunctional i've seen in my lifetime
and i know you know i'm about to be 40
and all that and haven't been around all
that long but this clearly takes the
cake and i think it is a real
possibility i mean of course it is in a
place like seattle too i mean pete
carroll he can understand of course it's
hit home up there that's been a real
issue in the city of seattle you know
portland oregon still going on there so
that hits home to the football players
and pete carroll you know the one thing
we've seen with his teams is he gets
guys that are not afraid to speak their
mind that are pretty smart you know well
thought out deep thinkers who bring out
these societal issues at times and yeah
they're going to confront them and he's
got the type of team and guys that are
you know
outside the box thinkers and you know
just that type of guy to where they
would be the type of team that would say
you know screw off we might not play
this weekend or threaten that or not
play or have some sort of really
creative boycott because they have a
leader like pete carroll too who doesn't
squash that an ownership that doesn't
squash that and i respect that and then
this is the other thing that bothers me
mike too much i hear this right now and
i've even had some friends say this to
me it has pissed me off like where
they've gone
you know
pete carroll just has to say that he
just has to say that because he's in a
he's in a locker room with all these
black people and i've had people
make comments to me like that oh you
just have to say that about politics
or this issue because you're on tv do
the networks make you say this what like
get the hell out of here no this is how
i feel this is really how i feel i'm not
pressured into this by anything i've
seen it i witness it there's issues with
white america and it has to be fixed
that's all there is to it and they're
blinded by it and their ignorance
continues to just you know hurt the
situation and this like blind eye
towards it is doing nobody any any good
and it's amazing to me that people would
be that cynical about an issue that is
so fundamental
to our fundamental right to life
right
that that people would think there's
anything other than a genuine care for
our fellow human beings we go back to
the original founding documents we
talked about this extensively after
george floyd was killed the right to
life liberty in the pursuit of happiness
it applies to everyone everyone is
included in that there should not be a
summary execution which is what george
floyd's murder was which is what almost
happened to jacob blake and his life is
forever changed even if he fully
recovers because he's paralyzed from the
waist down and as they've said it's
going to take a miracle to repair him so
that that's what's stunning to me and
i i think a lot of this chris
a lot of the concern that the players
have
isn't necessarily for them it's for
their children yes exactly for their
nieces and nephews for the next
generation and this is
i think the the message that i would
have for anyone out there who is white
who doesn't quite get it
if you have a child
if you have a niece if you have a nephew
if you have anyone under the age of 18
that you love and care about
friend god child anyone
that that act of sending them out to the
world is is
terrifying so think of those kids
and then pretend they're black
and think about how you'd feel then
sending those children out into
this world that we currently inhabit
we'll continue the discussion when we
return pft live back after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports